with the quickness
i'll get a picture of matt barnes as we
play his question thank you sir
yo what's up guys my name is aaron i'm
from connecticut
sure really what's in connecticut i mean
we got a bunch of dunkin donuts
and a couple of a couple of native
american casinos but yeah espn dog
you know bristol other than that there's
really nothing much but anyways i got a
i can't get a stinger for you guys and
it's got to do with getting down and
dirty
uh just you know it's a preference you
know some people prefer to have the
lights on
so that they could see you know the
operating procedure
and some people just like taking shots
in the dark if you feel what i'm saying
so i mean i gotta ask you guys what do
you guys prefer
lights on or lights off wax on wax off
in gang buzz buzz young gang gang
young matt barnes yeah man um what do
you think chappelle
are you a sexual man dim the lights oh
dim them up oh you like them the lights
get that r b going ooh you know all she
sees them teeth
yeah exactly she spells teeth
gonna be the day
that's what i do i pick up the guitar
before i get going you know two days
start playing a little song yep that's a
good question i'm trying to think of
what i like man
uh sometimes you catch yourself in the
mirror with the lights on my god
i need to get my ass on the treadmill
yeah so that can be kind of
inspirational
um i go lights on especially with a
baddie
yeah i go lights well otherwise you
could have sex with anybody if the
lights are off who gives a [ __ ]
i go lights on so i can see what i'm
messing with
i don't know i go maybe a lamp on or
something maybe a candle in the distance
there you go yeah i don't want a porno
set yeah i don't need great stage
lighting like the goddamn
know what i'm podcast somewhat girl let
me set this up
yeah hold on girl let me get this
[ __ ] podcast like nick let me borrow
what about you uh chan let's go let's
get some info i'll tell you right now
let me answer for you lights off
yeah true but you thought you want to
see you take his underwear off you know
yeah i'll respect that however i like
morning too we do morning
so the light's always on no matter what
sex in the morning yeah
and it's lighter jesse james
that's insane it lights off at night for
sure
in the morning huh hey and the morning's
tight yeah right i don't like how chin
said we'd do it in the morning that made
me feel weird
and you're late for work
you pick your way to start your day
though it's the best way to go
all day let's see yes that's the best
way to wake up i think if you're a man
that you get all tired then you gotta go
to work and do some xeroxing or whatever
or construction
yeah or construction or something man
i'm tired you know what i'm saying like
if you're wrestling big
gene all [ __ ] night you want to go
home and then
you know put in more cardio you got the
bruised ribs
i'm erect right now dude honestly are
you
no damn bro you have to think about a
dog i know when i'm a wreck you idiot
you gotta know bro you gotta go first
thank you a morning bird
uh yeah cause i'm usually tired at night
and then you you sleep it off
you re-energize in the morning you work
all day go back to bed
rinse repeat yeah that's fair
you guys are ill you changed man
brenda's right he different
difference i got that nashville swag
better than that
because you made it out i think you made
it out because you don't have these
state taxes you think you're better than
us look i'm just telling y'all what it's
like over there man there's no
just buffets everywhere unlimited food
yeah nice
oh yeah people are nice and you never
run out of gas
okay you could drive forever man good
people are friendly
yeah and it's just man everywhere you go
it's like somebody's like hey come on
over here buddy have this have you want
some
mashed potatoes you want some diamonds
you want some diamonds yeah anything you
want man people
it's like north korea oh it's crazy over
here i'm trying to smuggle out dogs
smuggle me back in your briefcase
i don't know man that's a lot to smuggle
yeah that ain't smuggling when it's that
big
you know ship me to nashville i'll beat
the [ __ ] out of big gene dog
damn boy we got 300 big ass jeans
dude it would take gina freaking two
months to get to 300. yeah
i'm just saying man i'm dang erect right
[Laughter]
[Music]
now
[Music]
is